seit drei jahren sind wir in einer
corona pandemie und die staatlichen
maßnahmen hinten dem alltag immer
hinterher die regierung hat bei den
bürger test versagt sie hat zum betrügen
eingeladen und die neue test verordnung
von karl lauterbach macht das ganze
nicht besser wollen es verschlimmbessert
die situation
ich bin selbst inhaber eines
testzentrums eine apotheke wir testen
seit über einem jahr und ständig müssen
wir immer wieder neue regelungen über
uns ergehen lassen die regierung fährt
eine stop and go strategie im herbst
wurden wulfert es abgeschafft drei
wochen später haben wir sie wieder
zugelassen und nun das gleiche nochmal
die regierung ist nicht lernfähig das
ist meine these am heutigen abend und
darüber diskutiere ich gerne mit ihnen
das ist sehr spannend fahren das nicht
lernfähig es haben ja auch viele bei den
bürger tests abkassiert also ich habe
auch gehört von verschiedenen menschen
das sind ja schon mit dem testzentrum
einer hat sogar seinen kontoauszug stolz
und freundeskreis herum gezeigt am
anfang konnte man wohl sogar nur striche
machen und man muss aber das gar nicht
digital anmelden hat da die regierung
auch nichts gelernt da hat die regierung
auch nicht gelernt das ist ja im grunde
genommen der ur fehler des ganzen dass
man jedem erlaubt ein testzentrum
aufzumachen ohne medizinische expertise
ohne ihm drohen ein leistungserbringer
im gesundheitswesen zu sein der geprüfte
sich als apotheke wenn ich eine apotheke
eröffnen muss ich muss meine approbation
abgeben ich muss ein führungszeugnis
hinterlegen ich muss mein
steuerrechtlich da habe ich nicht
aufgefallen sein das heißt ich bin immer
in der prüfpflicht und jetzt auf einmal
darf jeder testen ohne eine gewisse
schulung 20 minuten online schulung hat
glaube ich ausgereicht konnten sie es
denn am anfang auch mit strich lässt den
laden ohne die personaler dich natürlich
und ich bin ganz ehrlich von meiner
arbeit auch ehrlich gesagt dass oder wie
betrug
die einladung zum betrug von der
regierung ein und das hat das hat die
regierung im letzten jahr ja schon nach
zwei monaten gemerkt dann haben jetzt
erst einmal nachgeschärft aber nach
schärfen heißt nicht mehr kontrollen
sondern nachschärfen ist erstmal die
vergütung zu reduzieren und das gleiche
haben sie jetzt ein jahr später noch mal
gemacht das heißt die vergütung ist
nochmal fast halbiert worden und wir
schaffen damit ein bürokratiemonster
weil was ist
am strich gutes geld damit verdient
natürlich verdient man damit gutes geld
aber man muss auch sagen wenn man es
wirklich qualitativ hochwertig macht mit
geschulten personal mit ordentlichen
räumlichkeiten wir reden nicht über ein
müdes für den test ich glaube 12 euro
oder am anfang gab es 18 euro versehen
und sollten dann wurde es ab ob 50
runtergegangen und jetzt sollen ist in
bestimmten fällen neun euro 50 seien in
anderen 06 eur 50 da muss der bürger
eine zuzahlung leisten von drei euro
details zum einkauf im einkauf das kommt
immer darauf an also die
testphase ist immer weiter runter
gegangen das heißt im moment kaufen wir
ein für einen euro fünfzig ungefähr man
muss aber fairerweise auch sagen da
gehört ja noch viel viel mehr zu wenn
man qualitativ hochwertig macht da
gehört eine schutzausrüstung zu der
gehören masken zu desinfektionsmittel
mieten etc pp aber die arbeit in euro
waren dann viel zu hoch geworden
natürlich veränderungen also wenn ich
sehe einen euro fünfzig war ein
mathematiker und da seien damals war die
waren die war der wagen ein dort
deutlich höher das heißt die regierung
hat nach geschäft was sie aber nicht
gemacht hat dass uhr problem zu lösen
und zu sagen wir kontrollieren schaaf
der pellets mehr kontrolle nein nicht
mit nein nicht mehr kontrolle mehr
kontrolle bringt am ende nicht noch die
neue test verordnung wird dazu führen
dass jeder der möchte nicht in
anführungsstrichen kostenlos kann testen
lassen sondern im grunde genommen sich
zurück zu besinnen darauf dass man sagt
man lässt ist nur die machen die das
auch qualitativ hochwertig machen die im
system bekannt sind und die auch
vielleicht in drei jahren noch bei einer
steuerprüfung zu fassen sind wie viele
firmen werden nach dem ende der korona
teste liquidiert und sind dann für den
staat gar nicht mehr zu fassen kann
keine bereuen sie jetzt dass sie kein
testzentrum aufgemacht haben wenn ich
mehr so durchlese da muss ich sagen da
kann ich eigentlich anstand journalisten
lieber auch mal eins auf machen doch vom
halben jahr er durchaus ich hatte
gesehen bei uns im ort hat irgendwie ein
chinese geschlossen und aus den
räumlichkeiten war tatsächlich
testzentrum und so ging es ja vielen die
haben sozusagen gesagt na gut wenn wir
den laden die so zu machen müssen dann
machen wir eben was ich außerordentlich
lasse ich versteh ich finde dass das ist
ja auch marktwirtschaft ja das ist
einfach offene marktwirtschaft dass man
dass man sagt wenn der staat ist zulässt
warum soll ich es nicht tun wenn die
leute sagen ihr nehmt mir meinen job er
macht mir mein geschäft kaputt also muss
ich mir ein anderes suchen und dann ist
das eben ehrlich sagen wenn man so
fahrlässig handelt dann braucht man sich
nicht wundern aber wir haben ja auch
andere dinge also ich meine dass wir
irgendwann fangen wie auch unsere
bundesregierung hat sich ja
dilettantisch angestellt bei allen
möglichen dinge ich weiß ich was wir im
einkauf für die zwei masten bezahlt
haben oder im endeffekt bezahlen ja auch
alles wir ja also was mich stört
eigentlich ist dass all die menschen die
diese falschen entscheidungen getroffen
haben überhaupt nicht haftbar gemacht
werden wenn wir das alle wären ja dann
wären wir schon längst fällig ja wir
werden schon längst fällig aber in der
politik muss nie eingehen als das karl
lauterbach dass er immer noch im amt ist
ist eigentlich ein wahnsinn aber
auch aldi fehl entscheidungen die
getroffen worden sind all die milliarden
muss man sagen die rausgeworfen sind wir
kaufen impfdosen ein die wir
anschließend wieder entsorgen ja niemand
wird haftbar gemacht dafür für dieses
unser management und wir bezahlen das
als bürger alle am schluss das ärgert
mich
aber das ist ja im grunde genommen dass
das problem dass man im grunde genommen
ohne sinn und verstand maßnahmen er
lässt und regelung erlässt ohne zu
wissen was das in der praxis bedeutet
diese neue test verordnung geht ist
völlig weltfremd wer soll dann im
testzentrum kontrollieren es heißt wenn
man in innenräumen veranstaltungen
besucht dann hat man darf man weiterhin
test bekommen wenn man ältere leute
besucht die über 60 sind dann darf man
weiterhin einen test bekommen wie soll
ich das denn im testzentrum überprüfen
sie können dass sie können wir können
das neben der durch verordnung denen die
dusch protokoll können wir jetzt auch
das besuchs- motto kollege unsere
verwandten ja aber darauf wie
protokollieren und doch tut und am ende
des tages muss man ja wirklich sagen
herr lauterbach sagt ja mit weniger test
wird die qualität besser und die test
werden wertvoller das doch vollkommen
und mehr für den bürger auch dass wir
über bleibt